Dwan said confirmed officially where the
coup was underway but called for calm he
said a group within turkeys military had
attempted to overthrow the government
and that security forces in hid will in
his words have been called in to do what
was necessary a few minutes later after
that the Turkish military confirmed that
it had taken power now they said that
was in an effort to protect democratic
order they took control of a TV station
they put out that statement that they
wanted to reinstate the constitutional
order democracy human rights and
freedoms now it's worth reminding
ourselves at this point that the
military traditionally in Turkish
history's history sees itself as as a
guardian of the secular state the
Vanguard if you like and that over
recent years president Erdogan has been
accused of trying to make the country a
more religious country and of eroding
people's right to prepare protest
freedom of speech freedom of the media
as well so those are the that's the
background to the situation things
continued with reports then that the
president was safe but then there was a
huge question mark over where he was now
we now think that he had been in the
Turkish resource of marmaris but
crucially he was out of Ankara on out of
Istanbul which was obviously seen as an
opportune moment by these elements
within the military